rodrigo buenas tardes en efecto este
jueves los ánimos permanecen cambiados
luego de que en la víspera un grupo de
cientos de emigrantes de los 4000 de la
caravana que se encuentran apostados en
huixtla irrumpiera de forma violenta
haciendo el uso de la fuerza en contra
de las oficinas de emigración de esta
ciudad del estado de chiapas se
abalanzaron en contra de la línea de
protección de las vallas metálicas y
además empujaron a la línea de
protección de la guardia nacional que a
pesar de estar investidos con
equipamientos de antimotines no lograron
contener el peso de todas las personas y
una vez adentro lanzaron sillas lanzaron
vallas metálicas rompieron cristales y
con arengas de queremos los permisos
exigieron a las autoridades migratorias
que les entreguen este formato múltiple
de migración con el cual se puedan
movilizar por mexico atravesar méxico de
manera legal y no contar con ese temor
de que sean deportados o de que sean
capturados y enviados al centro de
reclusión siglo 21 en la ciudad de
tapachula
cunde el desespero porque las
autoridades no han enviado un mensaje
claro ni ninguna promesa de que les
vayan a entregar esta especie de rizado
como si lo hicieron en la caravana de
junio donde se entregaron más de 8 mil
permisos migratorios claro está con un
contexto muy distinto porque se estaba
realizando al mismo tiempo la cumbre de
las américas que hablaba de resolver el
fenómeno de la migración y andrés un
problema colateral de esta caravana es
que tiene bloqueada la carretera de la
costa sur de chiapas que detalles se
tienen al respecto
en efecto es la carretera que conecta a
guatemala con el sur de méxico y en
méxico conecta al estado de chiapas con
el estado de oaxaca por la vía costera
del pacífico en gran parte se ha podido
realizar este bloqueo los migrantes lo
han podido llevar a cabo por la
indulgencia del clima ya que ante la
ausencia de las lluvias han acampado
justamente en la carretera a diferencia
de las anteriores caravanas que
acampaban en polideportivos de las
ciudades los transportistas mexicanos
cientos de ellos se encuentran varados
desde hace más de 25 horas y han
criticado a las autoridades que no
cuentan con agua no cuentan con comida y
los critican que brillan por su ausencia
pero recordemos que sobre las
autoridades además recae el peso de las
medidas cautelares emitidas por la
comisión nacional de derechos humanos de
méxico que pide y exige que se proteja a
los migrantes porque en este grupo de
cuatro mil hay más de 1200 niños